Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es ist wieder Zeit für die Ligatur. Wir blicken auf die europäischen Top-Ligen und heute auch mal ein bisschen auf so manche Nationalmannschaft. Das ist doch mal was Neues hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 254. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und wenn ihr immer noch bei Twitter rumhängt, dann auch dort. Ich begrüße euch sehr zu Rasenfunk Kurzpass 254. Es ist mal wieder Ligaturzeit. Wir haben hier eine tolle Runde an unterschiedlichen Gästen. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian. Ich begrüße nicht ganz zu meiner Linken, sondern zugeschaltet, wobei örtlich gesehen ist er trotzdem immer noch links von mir, nur ein bisschen weiter. Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli.
Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, weil meine Orientierung dermaßen schlecht ist. Aber grüße euch.
Zwei mal eins, zwei gegen Eichmann. Hat man nicht im Rückspiel sogar geführt mit 1 zu 0? Dann hat das Eichmann also – naja gut. Aber so ist das eben. Jetzt wollen wir nochmal in die Liga gucken. David, da hast du uns noch ein überraschendes Thema mitgebracht, worüber ich mich sehr freue. Du wirst über Reims sprechen. Was ist da zu wissen?
Genau. Ich habe ein bisschen überlegt, habe ein bisschen geschaut über die Vereine, die ihr gesprochen habt in der Vergangenheit und dachte, ich bringe mal Reims mit. Und zum Einstieg, da ich ja jetzt tatsächlich ein paar Mal auch selbst jetzt höherer der Ligatur war und längere Zeit nicht dabei ist, mir aufgefallen, dass du – Ligaturist warst du. Ich war ein Ligaturist. Aber dann geht doch dein wunderschönes Wortspiel mit der Schrift als Ligatur von dort.
Ja, das stimmt eigentlich nicht. Aber das hat anscheinend eh niemand verstanden, warum es Ligatur heißt.
Also ich habe es nicht verstanden. Da stehe ich auch dazu.
Ligatur ist quasi ein – das kommt aus dem Schriftsetzen. Das ist das Verbinden von zwei Buchstaben. Und wir verbinden ja hier mehrere Ligen miteinander. Also es war eigentlich ein wunderschönes Wortspiel. Die Ligatur, die eben nicht nur eine Tour ist, sondern eben aus der Ligatur kommt. Aber es hat wirklich niemand verstanden. Außer vielleicht noch zwei andere Nerds da draußen.
Ist doch dann nur mit U, nicht mit OU.
Jaja, genau, klar, logisch.
Max, du weißt ja, was das über den Künstler sagt, wenn er sein Werk erklären muss, ne?
Ja, das kenne ich von meinen Witzen. Das hättest du nicht noch mal extra sagen müssen.
Also jedenfalls, da ich ja jetzt auch ein paar Mal zugehört habe, ist mir aufgefallen, dass so sehr ich Fußball interessiert bin und dass es häufig doch Städte und Vereine gibt, wo ich echt, also tatsächlich sagen müsste, ich könnte die Städte nicht auf der Landkarte finden in Spanien und ich weiß über die Vereine eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Deswegen mal die Frage an euch in die Runde. Was verwendet ihr mit Ras?
Ich weiß, dass man das S sagen soll am Schluss.
Den Verein irgendwas so? Wie? Historisch? Ist spannend.
Also ich verbinde mit dem Verein, das Usman Demirle da gespielt hat, um ehrlich zu sein. Liegt da jetzt ein bisschen nahe. Aber ansonsten, so historisch gesehen, wenig irgendwie.
War das nicht so der SC Freiburg, der liegt ein? Hab ich mir das richtig gemerkt oder ist das.
Ich gebe euch mal ganz kurz einen Aufriss. Also die Stadt liegt in der Champagne, Nordosten Frankreich, 200.000 Einwohner. Ist bekannt durch Kaiser-Krönungen, da könnte man das gehört haben. Jean D'Arc hat das damals zurückerobert, zum Beispiel, damit da Kaiser Karl VII gegründet wurde. Und das war nach dem 2. Weltkrieg. Darauf wollte ich hinaus. Der dominierende Fußballclub Frankreich. Die hatten 6 Titel, die hatten zahlreiche Pokale, die haben einen Großteil der Spieler bei der WM in Schweden 58 gestellt und waren zweimal im Finale des Europapokals der Landesmeister.
Ja gut, das hätte Uli jetzt wissen können, das ist ja schon Grundwissen.
Ich habe das ja nicht mal kommentiert, deswegen hätte ich das irgendwo stehen, aber ich habe es nicht im Kopf. Erprägende Duelle gegen Real Madrid, beide 56 und 59. Und mit Ramon Copa und Albert Bartheu und wie wohl diese Offensiv-Fußball damals genannt, wenn ein Club in der Champagne liegt. Wer da mehr hören möchte, es gab vom Hörfehler-Podcast im Sommer 22. Die Folgen 154 und 155, Geschichte des französischen Fußballs. Da sehr ausführlich und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dann ist der dortige Gast Olaf Wutke auch verantwortlich für den wirklich sehr, sehr schönen und exzellenten Wikipedia-Artikel zu raus. Wer da jetzt Lust hat, kann da gerne mal reinschauen. Das ist ein richtig schönes Lesestück. So, also jedenfalls. Dazwischen herrscht große, große Lehre. Die sind 33 Jahre nicht mehr. Klassisch gewesen seit 1979. Sie haben ihre komplette Trophäensammlung damals verkaufen mussten. Die haben sie aber später wiedergekommen, zum Glück. Weil tatsächlich, das ist ein Name. Die mussten in der sechsten Liga neu beginnen. Seit 2012 sind sie so wieder in der ersten Liga dabei, unten rum und jetzt in der aktuellen Phase seit 2018. Das ist ein Club, der mehr in die untere Hälfte gehört. Die Start der aktuellen Saison lief auch sehr holprig, man fiel da direkt unten rein. Dieses Jahr werden in Frankreich vier Teams absteigen. Das ist ja ein ziemlich harter Abstiegskampf, weil die Liga auf 18 Teams verkleinern will. Dann wurde im Oktober der Trainer Oskar Gassier entlassen und der Co-Trainer übernahm Interim. Der Co-Trainer hat jetzt am Wochenende, also nicht jetzt am Wochenende, sondern am letzten Ligaspieltag, sein erstes Ligaspiel verloren. Ras war 19 Spieltage unbesiegt. Habt ihr den Namen Will Still schon mal gehört? Weil der geistete ein bisschen durch die deutschen Fußballgazetten vor ein paar Wochen. Das ist nämlich der Trainer.
Ich habe aufgeschnappt, dass er Französisch mit französischem Akzent und Englisch mit englischem Akzent sprechen kann. Die wirklich wichtigen Dinge aus Frankreich, die bekomme ich mit.
Also der ist Belgier und sein Vater ist Engländer. Der Vater lebt seit 30 Jahren in Belgien. Und was von Will Still dann so rumgeistert als, glaube ich, Geschichte, auf die sich Journalisten immer sehr, sehr gerne stürzen, ist, dass er angeblich sein ganzes Fußballer taktisches Nerdwissen bekommen haben soll, weil er jahrelang Football-Manager gespielt hat.
Ja, doch.
Siehst du, die wichtigen Dinge kriegen wir mit. Und da hat sich Will Still jetzt auch unlängst geäußert, dass er ja irgendwie ganz schön und so weiter, aber das fände er jetzt noch ein bisschen dexpektierlich, dass das jetzt sozusagen die prägende Story ist, mit der er da charakterisierte. Weil natürlich stimmt das nicht so und da gehört auch deutlich mehr dazu.
Das spielt auch man auf FIFA, zur Wahrheit.
Also es gibt die Anekdote, dass eine Freundin seiner Schwester mal zum Abendessen da gewesen sei und irgendwann habe sie gefragt, können wir noch mal über das andere Satz Fußball sprechen. Will Still ist in Belgien aufgewachsen, hat da auch ein bisschen Fußball gespielt. Es heißt, er habe sehr englisch gespielt, viele rote Karten gezogen und hat dann Football-Coaching in Preston studiert, hat die U14 von Preston Northend trainiert und hat dann in Belgien von Yannick Ferrerat bei Saint-Tron, also bei Sint-Trudinese-VV, eine Chance bekommen, Videolist zu sein. Das hieß schon damals, er habe Dinge gesehen, die normal Leute nicht gesehen haben und mit 24 wird er dann in Lyase, jüngster Trainer der belgischen Liga-Geschichte. Der träumt übrigens noch, hat er auch öffentlich gesagt, der träumt von einem Job in der Premier League. Aber ich glaube nicht Tottenham, er sagte, bevor er zu West Ham gehen würde. Und der ist jetzt, wie gesagt, also 19 Spiele ungeschlagen, hat währenddessen nur neun Tore kassiert. Es läuft extrem gut. Bei diesen 19 ungeschlagenen Spielen sind auch zwei Unentschieden gegen PSG mit drin. Und Siege gegen Rennen, gegen Monaco, teilweise spektakuläre Siege gegen Lorient mit einem Hatschig von Balogun. Balogun ist so ein bisschen der, der ist von Arsenal ausgeliehen. Das ist eine der Stürmerentdeckungen in Frankreich. Teilt sich derzeit den zweiten Rang der Torschützenliste mit 17 Treffern. Neben so Leuten wie Lacazette und Ben Yedère hinter Mbappé. Der hätte jetzt gegen Marseille auch beinahe noch das 2. Nachspielzeit erzielt. Der Gänger war an Pfosten. Die letzte Niederlage davor war tatsächlich am 18. September. Da war der Vorgänger Oscar Garcia noch Trainer. Das ist schon teilweise auf Still zurückzugehen. Er hat ein sehr, sehr bislang unverrückbares 4-2-3-1 eingeführt, stehen defensiv sehr stabil, gutes Stellungsspiel, wenig Räume, die sie dem Gegner lassen, pressen aber sehr hoch und haben sehr, sehr variable Spieler vorne, die sich da so gegenseitig in der Offensive auch abwechseln. Da scheint auch keiner sich zu schade zu sein, mal von der Bank zu kommen. Also ein extrem gutes Mannschaftsgefüge da auch. Ob das jetzt tatsächlich für Europa reicht oder ob da Europa nicht sogar zu früh wäre, ist jetzt die Frage.
Immerhin den Abstieg vermieden mit 20 Punkten Vorsprung auf.
Den Abstieg sehr, sehr eindeutig vermieden gerade. Ich habe leider für die Hörer extra nachgeschaut. Also man kann zumindest in den nächsten zwei, drei Wochen auf der Zone-Grenze erstmal nicht sehen, weil die spielen jetzt gegen keine der Top-Klubs und der Zone zeigt ja normalerweise von der Liga nur die Spiele mit Top-Klub-Beteiligung. Die hatten sie ja alle schon hinter sich jetzt.
Aber wir sehen, ist sehr gut. Danke, dass du mich da nochmal dran erinnert hast. Ich habe einen Artikel auf The Athletic über Will Stil gelesen und das ist natürlich ganz fantastisch, wie ich mir da gemerkt habe, bei welchem Verein er überhaupt Trainer ist.
Der kostet doch pro Spiel ein paar Tausend, weil er keine ausreichende Lizenz hat.
Er hat es mittlerweile.
Das sind die spannenden Fakten.
Genau, genau, genau. Ist mittlerweile aber auch schon jetzt Geschichte, weil er hat jetzt offiziell seinen Trainerschein angefangen. Da muss man nicht mehr drüber berichten.
Ja, aber das ist doch schön, wie man dann über den Tabellen neunten der Liga auch sehr interessant sprechen kann. Lieben Dank dir, lieber David. Und ich würde sagen, jetzt zum Abschluss, nachdem die Zeit auch schon ein bisschen fortgeschritten ist, hätte ich gerne die Matches to Watch, also was am Wochenende müssen wir in den einzelnen Ligen beobachten. Da ich vermute, dass Uli Hebel mal wieder die Matches to Watch selbst moderiert, wird er darauf vorbereitet sein. Nein, nein, nein, an dem Wochenende gibt es nur City gegen Liverpool.
Also es ist nichts Erhellendes, nichts Neues, aber das muss man natürlich sehen. Also guter Zeitpunkt auch, 13.30 Uhr geht es da los, also Samstag noch bevor der ganze, also es soll ja in Deutschland auch ein Spiel geben, das einigermaßen interessieren könnte, aber das kann man sich, glaube ich, sehr gut anschauen. Und dann aber Arsenal auch bitte.
Die Frage ist übrigens, kann man sich sehr gut anschauen, wenn man es mit dem FC Liverpool hält, ne? Das ist ja die Thematik.
Ja, gegen CD sah es ja meistens gut aus. Und ich möchte mal auch nahelegen bitte, Plymouth Argyle gegen Bolton Wanderers, EFL-Trophy am Sonntag.
Ja, ja, ich sage einfach nur Ja. Ich sage Ja zu Plymouth gegen Argyle gegen die Bolton Wanderers. Aber es tut mir auch irgendwie ganz gut, dass ich nicht der Größe Nord bin in dieser Sendung. Da fühle ich mich immer so herrlich normal, wenn ich mit euch spreche. Christian, was muss ich in der Serie A verfolgen?
Ja, das ist auch relativ einfach. Da spielen am Sonntagabend Napoli gegen Milan, was ja eh an sich schon ein Kracher ist. Gerade für Milan geht es ja auch darum, im Champions League rennen zu bleiben. Schwer genug. Und Napoli gegen Milan spielen jetzt Mitte April auch noch zweimal gegeneinander, in einem anderen Spiel unter Champions League Aspekten. Dementsprechend dreimal Napoli gegen Milan jetzt in den nächsten Wochen. Da ist ordentlich Zündstoff drin.
Das kann man sich tatsächlich so vorstellen. In der Liga, was ist da wichtig? Gibt es da noch wichtige Spiele, Alex?
Es gibt ein wichtiges Spiel, das aber nicht direkt in der Liga ist, sondern in der Copa del Rey natürlich das Halbfinale-Rückspiel im Pokal. Wieder Klassikos. Man hat ihn ja vermisst. Es gab ja erst vier bisher. Daher gibt es direkt gleich wieder einen am Wochenende. Aber es gibt eher zwei Spiele, die ziemlich spannend sind im Rennen um die Champions League. Nämlich Vireal gegen Real Sociedad, das ist Sechster gegen Vierter und dann Atletico gegen Betis, das ist Dritter gegen Fünfter. Das Rennen um die Champions League ist sehr spannend. Sevilla mit Neu-Coach Mendy Libar hat ein kleines Abstiegs – Endspiel kommt zu früh, es sind ja noch genug Spiele – aber ein Abstiegskracher in Cádiz. Die beiden sind punktgleich.
Das sind auch ein paar Geheimtipps, die ihr hier bekommt.
Kann ja nicht jeder hier mit Liverpool gegen City glänzen.
Ist auch eine der wenigen Vereine, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, die Mendy Libar noch nicht trainiert hat, Cádiz.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Also tabellarisch einfach spannend. Es gibt einfach Spannenderes als der Meisterschaftskampf, logisch. Von daher, wir pricken ja auf die spannende Paarung.
Aber wirklich. Und was müssen wir uns da in der Liga zu Gemüte führen, David?
Ja, ich habe ja eben schon angedeutet. Ich habe mal geschaut, was wird denn überhaupt übertragen. Rennen gegen Lens kann man sich anschauen. Fünfter gegen Dritter. Die beiden Vereine wurden ja hier, wissen die Ligaturisten, wurden ja auch schon mal in den vergangenen Wochen besprochen. Ansonsten könnte auch – das ist Samstag 9 Uhr abends – und ansonsten könnte durchaus auch das Sonntag um 5 Uhr Spiel ganz interessant sein. Das ist Monaco gegen Strasburg. Da geht es für Monaco auch um Europa. Die sind aktuell zwischen Lens und Rennen eingeklemmt. Und für Strasburg geht es um den Abstiegskampf. Die waren da eigentlich schon ganz, ganz tief unten drin und haben jetzt aber einen kleineren Lauf, bei dem sie sich gerade wieder so ein bisschen rauskämpfen.
Und haben aber auch mit Dia Lo einen sehr erfolgreichen Torschützen vorne drin, den man sich ein bisschen angucken kann. Und bei Monaco haben wir ja Ben Yada sowieso mit dabei.
Genau, ja. Und Ben Seguir, den neuen jungen Shootingstar.
Ihr vier. Das hat wieder große, große Freude gemacht. Das war eine sehr schöne Sendung. Ganz herzlichen Dank an euch alle, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich danke immer noch neben mir sitzen Christian Bernhard. Danke dir.
Danke schön.
Danke an Uli Hebel. Danke auch. Danke an Alex Truica.
Sehr gerne. Danke ebenfalls.
Und vielen Dank schön, dass du mal wieder da warst. David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390. Danke dir, lieber David. Und dann wünsche ich euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, eine gute Woche. Viel Spaß mit den ganzen Top-Matches, die ihr jetzt gucken müsst. Sagt nicht, wir hätten es euch nicht gesagt, um was es da geht am Wochenende. Und dann hören wir uns hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Die nächste Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz wird Tobi Escher moderieren, den nächsten Frauen-Kurzpass, der erscheint am Montag. Die moderiere dann wieder ich. Und es gibt dann auch was zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga, das kommt in der nächsten Woche am Donnerstag. Bis dahin bleibt gesund und unterstützt bitte den Rasenfunk. Danke euch, liebe Grüße, ciao!